But I don't have time for fucking anything.
Hey, Mama.
I wanted to pop in here and commiserate with you for a second
because I've got one of those, too.
This is Levi. He's about seven and a half months and teething
and as we can see, fussy.
I actually just had to put him down cause it was nap time.
But the only difference between you and me is that
that's my third baby.
So I've Learned a little something through raising my other two.
And I'm gonna share that with you.
It's exactly as hard as you think it is.
Number one, you're not a bad mom for feeling the way you do.
Your identity will completely change
and is this is the growing pains of that.
But also it gets a lot easier.
And I know people say that,
but every six months you have a completely different baby
with completely different needs and completely different life stage.
Some of them are really shitty
and some of them are easier, probably.
And some days are gonna be better than others.
Hang in there. Get as much rest as you can. I'm with you.